joining us now with reaction former
Florida attorney general Pam Bondi along
with senior fellow at the Hoover
institution Victor Davis Hanson thank
you both for being here Pam we did a
little bit of quick research in
California where Disney Land is located
uh they do Disney does not have a
sanctuary country inside California
where they have their own distinct tax
status yet Democrats are losing their
mind over the fact that Florida is
simply leveling the playing field and
saying hey Disney you don't get to be
your own country
yeah that's exactly right Pete and those
woke Executives that live in California
pay about 40 percent more in their taxes
than the executives that live in the
great state of Florida so you know we
passed this bill in Florida and I'm so
proud of Wilton Simpson our Senate
President and our governor for signing
and and bringing them um to light on it
and this is why it's so important the
first bill the parental rights bill as
you said it is protecting five six seven
and eight-year-olds okay kindergarten
through third graders third graders from
not talking about sex in school
I think any parent in America would
agree with that
past done great law then Disney comes in
they lie about our governor they lie
about our Senate they lie about our
house they lie about what parents want
in the State of Florida and they're held
accountable what they did was they
didn't stay in their own lane their Lane
is entertaining families and making a
lot of money for their shareholders yet
they shined a huge Spotlight on
themselves this lost 55 years old none
of us actually knew the extent of the
Privileges that Disney had in their own
kingdom and now they're taken away
yeah and their Lane used to be wholesome
content that parents could count on and
now
turn on Disney plus and you don't know
what new woke series you're gonna you're
gonna see if you leave your kids
unattended Victor when you look at this
it used to be Democrats that would fight
against corporate carve outs or tax
breaks for big businesses now they are
falling over themselves to protect one
why this changed Victor
oh I don't think I think it's just a
matter of we're going to force this down
people's throats and how dare you object
to us I mean it's kind of Highly ironic
Disney's got a market capitalization
Pete of 300 million dollars and they're
worried about Disney has this autonomous
Zone and all DeSantis did in the
legislature they just said let's go back
to normality and Disney's in a bad place
because how many places in the United
States have 20 million people in an
all-weather you know climate maybe
Florida California and Texas and that's
about it you need a big population you
need warm weather so that they're at the
mercy and it's very ironic because
remember the last decade we've been told
uh that private business can really
Force these conservative states to their
knees so if they have ID laws Major
League Baseball will boycott them or if
South Carolina has just two bathrooms
and all of our California companies here
won't will shut out billions of dollars
so now it's sort of reversed that not
really it's not even equal yet but the
states are saying we can do this too we
can pass laws that reflect our values
just like you can boycott our States but
they they get hysterical because I think
that the subtext of all of this whether
it's critical race theory in the schools
or it's transgenderism or it's open
borders 51 don't agree with any of these
ideologies none of these agendas so they
either have to change the demography or
they have to indoctrinate young people
so when Wine Guard has to stop about
wars it's kind of ironic that she was
right that indoctrination of young kids
whether it was in the Third Reich or the
Soviet system or Mao's China was
essential to creating an autocracy and a
totalitarian ideology which you know we
know how that all ended for everyone and
so that's what they're doing because
they don't they can't win the people
they don't have a effective persuasive
agenda and people have rejected it and
there's they're going crazy and they're
saying well we got to go to the kids
then or we've got to bring in new people
or we've got to change the system
because we can't win anymore because
we've gone off the deep end
Pam that feels right it feels like the
woke versus the newly awake who realize
uh what they'd take it for granted for
quite some time what's been the reaction
honestly amongst apolitical Independence
inside Florida based on the
mischaracterization of this bill how do
they really view it
well Floridians everywhere I mean they
they can't believe I think Disney I
think people are giving up Disney plus
they're giving up their season passes
um you know Disney they didn't stay in
their Lane and they're wrong and they
lied about our state and they lied about
what our parents want in our state and
they are supposed to be the organization
that looks out for families yet they're
enjoying a privilege that Universal
doesn't enjoy SeaWorld doesn't enjoy our
museums don't have our aquariums don't
have and now we are leveling the playing
field in the State of Florida and
they're going to have to abide by it and
it was their mistake because they
brought this to light on themselves and
you know the in Florida we're not going
to put up with these woke corporations
it's unbelievable that we're even having
to talk about this and in our school
rooms and in our classrooms the books
that they're putting out there it's
truly unreal but in the State of Florida
we're going to look out for parents and
children and we're going to continue to
do that
Victor we don't have much time and it's
kind of a big question but do the best
you can
is the left capable of any
self-reflection based on electoral
viability or do they have to double down
because of their thirst for ideology and
control
in other ideologues they're not capable
of any uh concessions or moderation
that's what ideologues are they've
hijacked the old Democratic party and
they're gonna they would rather lose and
be ideologically correct than win and be
ideologically incorrect and these are
sins of not just commission P their
Omission that they assume that these
first second and third graders are
getting great education and they know
art and music and literature and uh
language and they they're so well taught
by these brilliant teachers that they
have time to teach transgenderism well
that that should be the last thing until
they get the basics and we know that our
kids are not getting a good education at
all
no you're exactly right I mean look out
in 2022 in the midterms if Democrats get
wiped out watch them say it's because we
weren't left enough are they capable of
learning I don't feel like they are Pam
Victor Davis Hanson thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else